la riche pendant la nuit de samedi à
dimanche Charlotte 26 ans a perdu sa
voiture à son réveil un véhicule
inutilisable le moteur a brûlé c'est le
cas de beaucoup d'entre vous pendant ces
violences urbaines quelle réparation
espérer dorénavant notamment de la part
des assurances le ministre de l'Économie
leur a demandé de faire un effort pour
simplifier les démarches accélérer les
procédures et réduire le montant des
franchises explication avec Sébastien
Branger ici dans ce quartier paisible à
deux pas du centre-ville de La Riche les
habitants se sont réveillés groggy ce
dimanche matin il était 4h du matin
quand le véhicule de Charlotte a pris
feu ce n'est que dans la matinée qu'elle
découvre les dégâts le moteur a
entièrement brûlé la voiture est
désormais bonne pour la casse je suis
descendu j'ai pas
j'ai déjà au début j'ai pas compris puis
après je me suis je me suis effondré
c'est peut-être qu'une voiture mais
c'est le sentiment aussi d'injustice qui
qui un choc en fait pour Charlotte la
voiture et son seul moyen de déplacement
atteinte de plusieurs handicaps elle en
est très dépendante mais très utile
peut-être un peu plus même que que dans
un cas normal étant donné que j'ai
plusieurs handicaps qui ne se voient pas
mais ma voiture c'était aussi mes jambes
donc moi j'ai pas j'ai pas moyen de me
racheter une autre voiture
actuellement donc je c'est dans le flou
je sais pas ce que je vais faire après
en cas d'incendie sur un véhicule le
propriétaire à 5 jours pour déclarer le
sinistre à son assurance le délai est
désormais étendu à 15 jours
autrement du ministre la baisse des
franchises une mesure qui est bien plus
compliquée à mettre en place pour les
assureurs l'autre est fort c'était pour
par rapport à la franchise surtout pour
les commerçants les élèves artisans qui
ont été qui ont des dommages donc de
trouver un moyen de baisser les
franchises ça aussi effectivement les
Fédération des assurances des compagnies
d'assurance peuvent faire l'effort et
ensuite ce qui est beaucoup plus
compliqué dans le cas de des commerces
et la la faire un effort sur les la
perte exploitation et la perte
exploitation c'est un tout compliqué
c'est un dossier assez lourd pour savoir
le montant exact que l'entreprise a
perdu pendant ce laps pour les personnes
qui n'auraient pas assuré correctement
leur véhicule ils peuvent faire appel en
dernier recours au civil le centre
d'indemnisation des victimes
d'infraction